script idea let's say you've seen
someone or something or an idea comes
into your head and you say I want to
write about that I want to finish 100
pages yeah what's your whole process
from page one to go this is terrible
there are things you're supposed to do
as a writer that you should do you
should make outlines make your character
break down so all these things that you
like do you make your cards you plot out
your story or a first and second third
I'll do any of that none of it that's
the perfect screenwriter yes that's when
it has the folded sock drawer yes that's
the guy who does it all correctly I
don't do any of it I like to sit and
think about the idea and then I like to
think about the character who that woman
or man is and what they're like and what
their world looks like and then I just
start to think about what the movie
might look like in my head and once I
sort of start seeing the movie itself in
my head then I start writing it I don't
know how it's gonna end necessarily
unless it's a thriller if it's a
thriller I need to know how it's gonna
end so I can know where I gotta go if
that makes sense you know because you
always want to have that ending that
people go home so you think of the
ending first like what would be a cool
hole and then okay how do I get there so
I go backward if it's a thriller if it's
not a thriller if it's just a story
about people in life in love or whatever
it is then I don't really think that
much about what's gonna happen I just
sort of think about the people and where
they are and where I want them to be
what the world's like what they enjoy
there's usually a lot of wine involved
because I enjoy some wine and what
happens is I end up writing I think
something that's much more organic and
much more
Here I am a writer and I can't find a
word what is the word organic and what
is it what's what's the word when
something just spontaneous Monday's
organic I end up writing something
that's more organic and spontaneous
because I haven't sort of telegraphed it
and kind of like when you're acting you
know you always hear don't play result
you know because you've read the entire
script so your character is on a journey
so you know what that journey is but the
character doesn't know so you don't want
to play like you know what's coming
because you'll telegraph it to the
audience I find the same thing works for
me as a writer by not knowing everything
when I'm writing I'm discovering it as
I'm writing and it makes the writing
process exciting for me because I'm like
sitting there at the keyboard and I'm
like this is great
you know what's gonna happen next I
don't know I can't wait to find out
either you know what I mean it's like
it's a spontaneous thing and then
hopefully the training and and and the
laws of inevitability that I try to keep
focused in my head you know kick in as
I'm writing and when it's done it's it's
a really great it's a really great story
but yeah III I like to look at it as a
living breathing story that's unfolding
as if I'm watching it and that drives me
toward the end because I feel like if I
do all the outline stuff for me if I do
all the outline stuff I've already kind
of done it already
so that's like oh I gotta write at all
hated all the hurry figured it out so I
just like to jump in start writing
you